Alexis your film many worlds why did you
use an improv based script as your guide
well okay I have done some writing in
the past I'm I call myself an expo it
because I actually went through a period
of tron developer career as a as a poet
which is very impractical you have to
teach poetry as well it's very difficult
thing to do I so I've done some writing
I've read a load of short stories once
which I i did send one of them off so I
had some I had some writing experience I
wrote a novel a novella once absolutely
nuts there that novella but when I came
to her too many worlds what's
interesting about many words or what I
found interesting about many worlds is
that for members of the audience we're
going to have their bio signals red so
it'll be a little bit like I'm wired up
with a microphone they were going to be
wider one of them with measuring their
perspiration one of them measuring their
brainwaves one of them their heart rate
and one of them their muscle tension
were they gripping the seat or whatever
and then this would be analyzed by
computer and a different edit of the
film would be selected live in the
cinema based on what's called their
arousal level basically depending on how
physically intense they were coming over
as being so thing with that you can't
just have one scripts because I say it's
different edit it was actually a
different story so there were four
different stories they all started the
same then they split into two then each
of those two split into two now it was
just a short but still writing for
different stories for my first script it
not only seemed like a very hard work to
write these four because writing for
short script and writing one script that
has four ways through it is very
different because when you write for
short scripts they can all be different
maybe different styles different stories
or whatever but when you write for
scripts where it's actually one script
they have to have a coherence a
storyline and a film ability and all of
these things which are
why very difficult to do would have been
for me as first time scriptwriter had
been very very difficult to do now I'd
seen them goodbye promise and I I
thought well this this is good you know
this this doesn't seem it's not like
you're watching it in oh yeah this is
improvised oh yeah this is improvised
you know and I I thought I wonder what
would happen if I because I kind of what
would happen if I wrote the stories I
think what I did first with many words I
wrote the story that with full routes
through it and when I say write the
story of literally just as it came to my
head you know she does this he does that
he says this she says that and you're
not going to write the whole script that
way there's this and and I thought what
if I that's what I gave to the actors
and ice and then worked with them to
rehearse and to come up you know this is
so it's got suggested dialogue and then
they could try that and then I could say
like I need these concepts put into it
and interestingly the two actors that
were speaking the most had a lot of
experience of improv and working
together doing improv how fortunate that
that was the case I probably more
fortunate than I realized at the time so
I worked with them to do that and
afterwards I thought well actually this
is quite interesting because the human
mind you know it's we naturally think in
multiple strands we think in many worlds
we think you know what am I going to do
today I might do this I might do that
oui oui oui and when we're fearful we
think of all the different scenarios we
write multiple scripts you know they're
not scripts multiple stories in our
heads of what's going to happen and so
the human mind very naturally thinks in
terms of multi branching scripts but it
doesn't write in those it's so having
having a script where people had to
think it to bring it to like that to act
it to bring it to life was more natural
than trying to write a four-way script
because what I was saying to the actors
in fact the actors knew the script
better than I did in the sense that by
the end of the film I was saying to them
so what did yawns meant to be directing
this I was like so what did what's this
one and then this route through the
script what do you doin in that route
they knew it bad to me because the human
mind is naturally good at thinking in
terms of multi paths but it's a lot
different when you're the writer if
you're trying to do that and I'm so glad
that I kind of had the inspiration it
was it was it was a goodbye promise
there's also a film that you folks
reported on sat on a subway train that
use some improv as well so it's both
from the film courage website that I
heard about these things and that kind
of inspired me to try this that's the
background
you